ausgeschlafen die zeit wurde mal wieder
umgestellt und vielleicht erinnert ihr
euch vor der letzten zeit um stellung im
frühjahr gab es große diskussionen schon
letztes jahr gab es eine große umfrage
mit 4,6 millionen teilnehmern zwei
drittel davon übrigens aus deutschland
und über 80 prozent hatten gegen die
zeitumstellung gestimmt dieses gut
schaffen wir die zeitumstellung ab nur
in welcher zeit wollen wir dann
permanent leben permanente sommerzeit ja
meinte winterzeit die eu-kommission chef
juncker sprach sich für permanente
sommerzeit auswahl die bei der umfrage
beliebter war
millionen haben geantwortet sind der
auffassung dass es so sein sollte dass
die sommerzeit in zukunft sehr viel zeit
viel zoff der kommission dafür werben
dass man dann die bürger fragen auch das
tun muss was die bildung zum ausdruck
bringen wie seht ihr das dauerhafte
sommerzeit oder dauerhafte winterzeit
stimmt hier oben ab wieder ist gar keine
umfrage richtig das ist nämlich gar
keine meinungsfreiheit wie wir unsere
uhren stellen hat echte biologische
auswirkungen auf unseren körper
deswegen sollte diese frage auch
biologisch chronobiologische bewertet
werden was die zeitumstellung genau mit
unserem körper anstellt und in welcher
zeit die permanent leben sollten das
klären wir jetzt
[Musik]
als ihr wisst ja die sommerzeit ist die
zeit wo wir eine stunde früher aufstehen
müssen eine stunde früher als normal
zeit sprich winterzeit das heißt die
normale zeit die galt bevor die
zeitumstellung eingeführt wurde ist die
winterzeit heißt ihr euch schon mit dem
thema beschäftigt habt dann seid ihr
vielleicht über folgende
expertenmeinungen gestolpert sommerzeit
macht uns ticker dümmer grantiger kann
das seien immerhin sprechen wir hier von
nur einer stunde abweichung von
normalzeit schauen wir uns mal genauer
an wie unsere innere uhr mit der äußeren
uhr zusammenhängt dass wir alle eine in
der eu haben wisst ihr schon aus diesem
video diese innere uhr ist tatsächlich
in unseren genen kodiert die jeden tag
bestimmte proteine produzieren zyklen
weise diese proteine nennen wir der
einfachheit halber uhren proteine und
weil es uhren protein deck ist kann es
gehen wieder abgewiesen werden es kann
also wieder neues protein produzieren
und der ganze zyklus fängt wieder von
vorne an und das ganze dauert ungefähr
24 stunden manche menschen sind
genetisch bedingte lerchen das heißt
frühaufsteher und früh zu bett gehe
andere menschen sind genetisch bedingte
eulen das heißt spät aufstehen und spät
zu bett gehen hey lerchen haben eine
innere uhr bzw eine innere tageslänge
die kürzer ist als 24 stunden haben eine
innere tageslänge die länger ist als 24
stunden
das ist etwas was nur im schlaflabor
sieht im alltag ist war uns allen so
dass wir uns mit dem tag synchronisieren
und um die tageslänge von gelaufen ist
und ich denke das ist lars unser
hauseigener my lips schlafforscher wie
ihr wisst ist lars seit januar festes
team mitglied und bekannt für
bestechende grafiken auf seinem
kühlschrank also das hier ist ein tag
mit sonnenschein und umwelt und das hier
wäre unsere in abobo ist normalerweise
schön synchronisiert so dass sie gas
gibt und wir gas geben wenn es draußen
und wenn es so ist dann stehen wir auf
hohe zeit wenn wir jetzt nach new york
city
dann ist es da selbst stunden früher als
bei uns das heißt unsere innere uhr die
sechs stunden
die kriegt mit dass sie gestimmt und für
die ganz sich anzupassen aber dies
schaffe ich die ganzen sechs stunden auf
einmal sondern immer nur einen teil
davon einmal möchte ich ein konkretes
beispiel haben sie schafft an einem tag
ein gesicht das heißt sie würde am
ersten tag sich um zwei stunden
baustellen geht es nur noch vier stunden
nach dem nächsten tag schätze sich doch
immer wieder ein drittel formen sollte
so dass wir ungefähr 67 tage brauchen um
den new yorker uns ganz auf unsere
innere uhr ist also trägt sie braucht
ein bisschen und veränderungen
anzunehmen
man kann auch sagen unsere innere uhr
ist ein starker ostinato man muss sich
sehr stark entschieden um sie nur so ein
bisschen zu verstellen
wenn ihr sähen schwach aus den nato
könnte man sie sehr leicht verstellen
und dann gibt es auch keinen jetlag dann
willst du dich immer sofort an die neue
ortszeit
das hört sich erstmal an das eher das
knappe wenn das wäre zu überlegen dass
unsere evolution und ehrlich daran
angepasst hat in den urlaub zu fliegen
sondern dass wir eine stabile
verlässliche innehaben die sich zum
beispiel nicht aus dem tritt bringen
lässt wenn es mal nach dem gewitter
jetzt geht oder so was
deswegen ist es sehr sinnvoll dass
unsere in ruhe ein starker us senator
ist kein schach aussehen es hat aber
konsequenzen für unseren alltag nehmen
wir an ich wäre jetzt wie die meisten
menschen eine leichte eule mit einer
inneren tageslänge von 24 stunden und
zehn minuten um mich jetzt mit dem
echten tag zu synchronisieren
der nur 24 stunden hat muss ich meine
innere uhr jeden tag umstellen und zwar
jeden tag um zehn minuten vorstellen
also mai ist in new york und hier
überwiegend sechs stunden sagt jeden tag
kann die sich im detail vorstellen und
dann kommt sie irgendwann an den punkt
an wurde ja oder im new yorker
tagesanfang genau 30 minuten vor meiner
uhr von ihrem inneren tagesanfang kommt
und diese 30 millionen unterschiedliche
genau aus um die innere uhr
vorsicht das wäre jetzt in unserem
beispiel also mit meiner inneren
tageslänge von 24 stunden und zehn
minuten eine punktlandung denn damit
käme ich ja jetzt auf die perfekte
tageslänge von 24 stunden und das heißt
dass sie am nächsten tag wieder hinauf
zur gleichen zeit aufwacht sondern
wieder gefühlt der tag 30 minuten zu
früh anfängt und das heißt dann ja genau
um die natur wieder genau zehn
vorzustellen so dass sie jeder dann auch
da raus kommt also sie pendelt sich bei
diesen 30 minuten zu spät einen oder 30
minuten später als jemand der schon
genetischen 24 stunden länger
natürlicherweise bringen
das ist also der grund warum eulen mit
einer längeren inneren tageslänge
spätaufsteher sind wäre jetzt mal eine
innere tageslänge 24 stunden und 15
minuten
dann würde sich mein innerer tagesanfang
entsprechend bei 45 minuten nach dem
tatsächlichen tagesanfang einpendeln und
das ist der grund warum wollen und
lerchen sich im tagesrhythmus stunden
unterscheiden können obwohl die
unterschiede der natürlicheren tages
sollen minutenbereich sind okay aber was
ist jetzt dieser äußere tag wonach
richtet sich unsere innere uhr
verschiedene dinge können so genannter
zeitgeber sein das können regelmäßige
mahlzeiten seien regelmäßige aktivitäten
wie sport aber der stärkste zeitgeber
ist das licht und dass es nicht
verwunderlich aus evolutionärer sicht
und schließlich ist der tägliche wechsel
von hell und dunkel genau der grund
warum wir eine innere uhr entwickelt
haben bei licht macht es jetzt einen
großen unterschied wie hell das licht
ist also helles licht verstellt unsere
innere uhr viel stärker als schwaches
licht in unserem beispiel sind wir jetzt
von folgendem ausgegangen
nämlich wenn das licht gefühlt 30
minuten zu früh kommt verstellt sich die
innere uhr um zehn minuten wenn das
licht jetzt aber sehr schwaches dann
muss es vielleicht 45 minuten oder 50
minuten gefühl zu früh kommen damit sich
unsere innere uhr um zehn minuten
verstellt für menschen mit der üblichen
inneren tages länge von etwa 24 stunden
und zehn minuten heißt das je schwächer
zeitgeber ist desto später am tag
pendelt ihr euch ein also wenn ihr zum
beispiel den ganzen tag im büro sitzt
oder formschnitt rechner
werdet ihr zu spät aufstehen wenn ihr
aber dafür viel helles tageslicht
abbekommt pendelt ihr euch wieder näher
am tatsächlichen tagesbeginn einfluss
des tageslichts kann man auch sehen wenn
wir uns menschen im osten und westen
deutschlands anschauen
unsere ostgrenze geht die sonne nämlich
eine halbe stunde früher auf als im
westen
und die menschen im osten stehen an
freien tagen von alleine früher auf als
die menschen im westen all die anderen
sachen die wir regelmäßig machen also
der wecker das frühstück die arbeit das
sind alles schwache zeit gebe
im vergleich zum licht und wenn wir uns
nur darauf verlassen dann werden
moderate spätaufsteher schnell zu eulen
anders gesagt der weg bringt nichts uhr
morgens aus dem bett
aber er reicht nicht aus um meine innere
uhr ausreichend umzustellen was jetzt
passiert wenn sich die sozialen jetlag
ähnlich über möchten ist unsere ihre
ruhe
gegenüber der tageszeit verschoben und
deswegen gehen wir dann zur arbeit so
schwindet teils zeit wo wir eigentlich
unsere erinnerung noch auf schlaf steht
abends steht sie noch nicht auf schlaf
fans eigentlich schlafenszeit ist
deswegen lange wie ein und schlafen jede
nacht zu kurz bei der rwe konzern wieder
auf schmeißt ja ich häufig dann tag für
die halt ein schlafdefizit an gut wie
ungesund schlafen handelt ist haben wir
schon in diesem video erklärt und der
soziale jetlag korreliert mit
verschiedenen problemen und zwar genau
die die man erwartet wenn die mal einen
chronischen schlafmangel also zum
beispiel nicht mit erhöhtem risiko für
diabetes stimmungsschwankungen und
natürlich eingeschränkt
die leistungsfähigkeit wenn man ist sich
so macht daher kommt also die
schlagzeile dicker dümmer grantiger denn
es ist davon auszugehen dass genau
solche probleme zunehmen werden deswegen
raten chronobiologen von einer
ganzjährigen sommerzeit ab permanente
sommerzeit würde bedeuten dass all die
menschen die jetzt schon unter sozialen
jetlag leiden dann noch eine stunde
früher aufstehen müssten und das
tageslicht wird ihnen nicht dabei helfen
das tageslicht bleibt ja so wie es ist
wir entfernen uns nur mit unserem alltag
weiter von unserer inneren uhr im winter
würde uns die sommerzeit besonders zu
schaffen machen denn im winter haben wir
kürzer tageslicht es ist auch nicht zu
hell geben sommer und wir kriegen davon
auch nicht so viel ab weil wir nicht so
viel rausgehen das heißt im winter ist
der zeitgeber viel schwächer
das hieße für die meisten von uns dass
wir stärkere spätaufsteher werden aber
was ist mit den lerchen mit den
frühaufstehern wäre es für die nicht
andersrum ungerecht mache ich hier nur
euren lobbyarbeit also erstmal bäumen
und lächelt dass das sind nur die
extreme also die meisten von uns
irgendwo dazwischen aber ein großteil
der bevölkerung ist so er auf der
bayerischen seite es heißt es die mehr
leute die diese probleme haben also dem
vorjahr schnitt aber davon abgesehen ist
viel wichtiger punkt die unser alltag
normalerweise aufgebraucht ist
normalerweise ist morgens die arbeit und
abends die files
das heißt für lerchen ist es im
normalfall wenn sie abends schon früh
müde sind viel leichter zu sagen sorry
ich dass die party heute ausfallen ich
bin zu müde und für euren ist das
meistens ein bisschen schwieriger
tory-chef tiefschlag morgenstunde länger
weil sonst nicht immer so müde verstehen
sie oder
deswegen kommt dass beim jährlichen auch
deutlich seltener wollen dass sie gegen
napoli weniger als zwei prozent der
untersuchten menschen haben die
negativen sozialen jetlag also dass ich
abends noch unter der woche regelmäßig
aktiv sind obwohl eigentlich die in der
branche geschaffen steht über die hälfte
der leute sozialen jetlag in die andere
richtung
von einer stunde oder mehr das heißt sie
müssen regelmäßig morgens raus obwohl
ihr körper eigentlich noch nicht bereit
das ist unklar cayman r gegen gestein
mit maßnahmen die regelmäßig ausgehen
ans tageslicht vielleicht zu hause noch
ein tages haben wir benutzen und abends
darauf achten dass man nicht nur auf
fernsehbildschirme guckt aber das heißt
kämpfen darum kämpfen dass unsere innere
uhr schon mit der mit dem tag
synchronisiert und mit der sommerzeit
müssen wir einfach stärker kämpfen es
ist schwieriger als mit der winterzeit
jetzt sagen manche vielleicht wenn ich
jetzt abends länger an tageslicht habe
und dadurch mehr freizeitmöglichkeiten
dann ist mir dieser zugewinn an
lebensqualität eventuelle
gesundheitliche nachteile wert das ist
prinzipiell kein schlechtes argument nur
um eine gute entscheidung treffen zu
können müssen wir die gesundheitlichen
konsequenzen erstens natürlich
akzeptieren
und zweitens so genau wie möglich kennen
um eine vernünftige abwägung zu machen
und hier muss man tatsächlich festhalten
wie dick dohmen traurig wir durch
permanente sommerzeit werden würden ist
derzeit noch nicht klar wir wissen
derzeit auf jeden fall ist würde in eine
unvorteilhafte richtung gehen wie stark
der effekt ist das müsste man mit
empirischer forschung messen das
tückische an falsche schlafrhythmus und
schlafmangel ist dass sich die folgen
schleichend und langfristig einstellen
das heißt man merkt nicht so schnell
wenn man sich selbst durch einen
ungesunden lebensstil schadet doch bis
wir diesen schaden genauer beziffern
können gibt es jetzt schon erkenntnisse
aus der chronobiologie die uns im alltag
sehr viel helfen können zum beispiel weg
von dieser denke der frühe vogel fängt
den wurm in unserer arbeitswelt nein wir
sollten uns überall wo es nur geht
gleitzeit einführen damit alle
chronotypen und von euren bisherigen im
einklang mit ihren biologischen rhythmus
arbeiten können oder spätere schulzeiten
in weiterführenden schulen weil gerade
jugendliche einen besonders späten
rhythmus haben darum ging es in unseren
letzten video selbst für die
schichtarbeit gibt es chronobiologische
konzepte die sie verträglich erwachen
könnte
doch all diese ratschläge der
chronobiologen werden seit jahren
ignoriert
insofern bin ich froh dass
der entscheidung zur zeitumstellung
jetzt nichts auf basis irgendwelche
umfragen getroffen wurde sondern dass
die entscheidung jetzt erstmal vertagt
wurde auf voraussichtlich 20 21 und ich
kann nur hoffen dass bis dahin klar wird
dass es sich hier nicht um eine
meinungsfreiheit sondern um eine
medizinische wenn ihr das video bis
hierhin gesehen habt gehe ich davon aus
dass euch das thema sehr interessiert
deswegen hier zwei videos für euch falls
sie noch nicht gesehen habt einmal unser
letztes video zur inneren uhr das habe
ich heute schon ein paar mal zitiert und
mein quarks experiment wo ich meine
persönliche innere uhr habt bestimmen
lassen durch einen bluttest wir sehen
uns bald und bis dahin bleibt sicher